nuclear power has been a reliable source
of energy for 70 years but it comes with
the risk of a meltdown as we saw in
Chernobyl in 1986 in Fukushima in 2011
after Chernobyl Russia ordered a sixteen
hundred square mile area around the
plant abandoned forever but a very
different plan is underway in Fukushima
here's correspondent Mariana van Zeller
in Japan the Fukushima Daiichi nuclear
power plant has reportedly lost control
after an earthquake and tsunami
triggered a meltdown the radiation is
streaming out of the Daiichi complex
this is a catastrophic disaster
[Music]
I'm here in Fukushima exploring one of
the town's abandoned by the disaster
radiation is still too high for people
to live here this looks like it used to
be a beauty salon it had a lot of damage
this looks like it used to be a flower
or plant shop we have to be you know
very careful with what we touch or where
we stop because there's all this sort of
radioactive dust and particles
everywhere oh wow look at this whoa this
is a retirement home everywhere there's
just evidence of panic to get out of
here as fast as possible it's really a
time capsule of a really bad disaster
that happened here
[Music]
the Daiichi nuclear power plant sits on
the easternmost
edge of the Fukushima Prefecture when it
blew it spewed radiation across dozens
of towns triggering a 12-mile evacuation
zone that's still partially in effect
today the plant itself is still the most
hazardous site if Japan is encouraging
people to move back
how have conditions improved in the
seven years since the disaster I'm
meeting up with radiation researcher as
B Brown who is able to get special
access to take us to the plants let's
head out so this is an area that people
have still up another need permission to
get in there
so we've obtained the permission as B
says were okay to spend the short time
there but I'm going to play it safe and
stay in my protective gear
whoa yep that's it Fukushima Daiichi
[Music]
we are so close so no one has been in
there since the disaster actually
there's 5,000 people working there
it's a massive cleanup they can get into
parts of the buildings but they send
robots in to take video and to do work
Wow people can't even go in there the
radiation is so high I mean it's
thousands of times higher get in here
how long would a person be able to
survive in there a couple of minutes you
would get so much radiation damaging and
killing your cells that your organs
would start to fail there may be some
way to clean it up in 20 years or so to
make it livable but it's an incredibly
daunting task still Japan has taken on
the most expensive nuclear cleanup ever
attempted worldwide the government
claims that by removing the top inches
of soil where toxins have settled it
will make the land safe again to live
for seven years workers have been moving
inch by inch town by town digging out
layers of poisonous waste dropping it
into plastic bags and storing it at
temporary sites
these are all the bags with the nuclear
waste I mean it looks like hundreds of
thousands of bags just on this one site
in parking lots fields and abandoned
yards throughout Fukushima there are 9
million bags of waste and Counting
[Music]
Japan says the cleanup effort is working
and towns on the edge of the evacuation
zone are safe to resettle in 2015 they
deemed Nara ha 12 miles south of the
reactor sites the first town ready to
reopen yet less than half of the 7400
residents returned
condoisseur all Mariana yeah right it is
you have a beautiful house how long have
you lived here for my difficulties Wow
about a year and a half after new raha
reopened the government cut off
subsidies paying for evacuees to live in
temporary housing they hoped residents
would come home but many chose to move
elsewhere oh wow and although the
government claims the land is safe
Eni is not convinced so he's willing to
put his life in danger to clean up his
place most of the places around here
it's the government workers that are
removing the contaminated soil but
you've decided to do it yourself why
come the mascara competing and how much
time did I take you all something good I
forgot that was it now can you show me
how you do it
[Music]
the top layer is all toxic soil so in
order to decontaminate it you really
have to ask of a blue sky
yeah much sky in the conquer in the club
you wanna go for a visa singing I say
you must earn it on a horse on all day
seeing is that it doesn't see that soon
are you having any kind of money it's
not just fear of radiation preventing
residents from returning to neuro ha
konnichiwa normal after years of
abandonment towns in the area have been
overrun by wild boars they're ravaging
homes and everything in their path no
Sakamoto - god you're a not so good -
mom didn't have each other asshole no
cover the night the boars are not only
aggressive and known to attack their
radioactive to contaminate and this
evening
how many wars have you caught this way
even what did they talk later mm hog
sight they were mother a little bit
delayed Muslim name so when the war
comes in he triggers the wire and the
gates closed yet Scootie to deepen its
we do I know more you know so then they
so you think we have to go because they
think they've caught another war in one
of the other traps and they want to go
check it right now
[Music]
it's dangerous carbonates they attack
you look at the chemistry being held by
something around his foot no I'm not
angry
what's wrong honey that correct Monsieur
it's a big one
Imam or continued co-conspirator abrao
hug each other I'll come in handy for an
ad for an ID he's taking out his gun and
he's about to shoot that I was awful
he shot him right on the head and he's
dying right now
oh this is really sucks watch the
challenges in Arafah seem overwhelming
still Japan is pushing for more
residents to come home even with all the
cleanup and rebuilding I can't help
wondering will it ever be enough can you
give me an idea of how much money has
been spent and trying to get people to
come back caught you your name man you
are a kook can you guarantee with a
hundred percent that it's safe right now
for people to come back and then I see
llamada de nada que tu casa de nada
Tomita so no shoo him wha Coco not an
abaya moon Oh take out the killing can
cousin am I stuck in two more hmm ma
choosing this final night ego se como ha
ah knowing our tiny rock I wanna teach
you the key to pay about you deserve a
safe
we're going to check out one of the
government's most significant efforts in
Arafah a state of the art project that
every community in the world needs to
thrive we're visiting this new school
that they just built right here in the
parking lot there's this radiation
monitor so that parents when they drop
off their kids at school every morning
they can make sure that it's safe for
the kids to go to school
this is a beautiful school I thought I
was calling cutouts guy had a metamer
sir
so because of the radiation levels you
had to demolish the previous school and
build an entirely new one yes what is
this is the sixth grade sixth graders Oh
chemistry yes they're good students of
it this is a beautiful school they spent
millions of dollars building it and yet
it only has 68 students it's built for
300 why us but enrollment has doubled
since the first year a promising sign
that others will follow
the atashi wa koko no Kodomo tachi oh
sorry Otto whoa smoke rising you want to
remaster Senate seat in the Senate
oh no hostess n-no do token see us at
OPA
sorry Kurosawa sake Latanya doors that I
Iike SAT children are actually the most
vulnerable for radiation so every day
mr. orgy here prepares all the local
food that they have from this region men
dusted for radioactivity have there been
times where you've checked under the
radiation levels have been too high
thank you you do know how many times a
day do you have to do this
Octavio de la cosa nostra Monod a
hundred Puna it's really crazy all that
they have to go through to just make
sure that the food is safe enough for
the kids here to eat
okay coming back from a disaster of this
scale is a decades-long endeavor but for
some families living elsewhere is simply
not an option something you could who
sends us a mama I know I read this
okey-doke
we're gonna move on the motor to reduce
the current and this kiddo
what does it was it the co sin date item
with Hamas the Yamauchi family moved
back a year ago they had to demolish
their old home and everything in it they
rebuilt from scratch
were you scared to come back - Shiva so
many are no mechanical to this every
coma support they are super know they
never saw you talk away a pre know Korea
sweetie today I came on machine time
over yeah promote a not an agony so you
took over semiotic IEC that matter how
much Eva
more maritime was me know cosas de mocha
no I know pocketing a moderate oh my
team Okazaki Ricky Massey
I know Sudan Rozonda must fear in 2020
Fukushima's recovery efforts will be
center stage at the Olympic Games in
Tokyo a hundred and fifty miles away to
honor the region a torch relay will
begin in Fukushima so I've been in
Fukushima for a few days now and it
seems that with every tragic story
there's also a story about hope and
people really trying and fighting to
bring this place back to life quartz
silicon season listening King our guitar
neck segunda terasaka died
Kampai cursor Fukushima
[Music]